hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 1971 candidates series
it's a Ticknor petrosyan versus Bobby
Fischer
this is game six and I know that in the
previous video of the series during Game
five I told you that a year ago I
already made a video on Game six and
that you're more than welcome to check
it out you know now if you're if you
don't want to wait for me to redo the
video but in fact the video I made was
about gays in Game seven so I never
actually made a video on Game six this
is the first time I'm making a video on
Game six petrovin versus Fischer and the
game you saw as I saw many of you have
seen it was actually Game seven so as I
said I will be remaking Game seven but
those of you who haven't checked it out
after this video you are more than
welcome to check out the Game seven
I'll link the description will be in the
I'll link to the video will be in the
description below also it it's a nice
opportunity for you to check out how
this channel evolved during the course
of the past year so like we said first
game went to the Fisher a second game
Petrosyan immediately retaliated with
the white pieces and ended Fischer's the
winning streak then we had three very
nice draws the two very competitive
draws in one very quick draw that
followed the game Spassky vs Petrosyan
from 69 and here we are at Game six it's
a it's a very exciting game I'm sure you
will enjoy it so let's dive straight
into it
Petrosyan has the white pieces here and
he opens with Knight to f3 so a nice
reti opening c5 by Fischer we have b3 in
the d5 so Fischer is a officials
response is very principled when your
opponent doesn't control the control the
center with his pawns you should always
control the center with your own pawns I
mean white will control the center only
he will do it with pieces some hyper
hyper modern ideas but by Richard retty
none other than it's okay Bishop to b2
we have
f6 one of the this is obviously one of
the positions where f6 is actually fine
to play it's a counter to this powerful
Bishop and also with this f6 move
Fischer prepares c5 we have c-4 Fischer
pushes the pawn before we have d3 and
now comes C 5
so already you can see that if you're if
you're not a big fan of passive
positions you don't want to be white
here
we all know petrosyan to the Pitt Rosen
doesn't really care whether he plays
active or passive position so you can
play anything so he doesn't mind playing
this okay we have III Knights to e7
Bishop to e2 and night e to c6 Knight B
to d2 by Petrosyan Bishop to e7
we have castles castles and now II for
further closing the position a single by
Fischer and here it's time for you to
decide what you want to do here with the
white pieces if you're like me you're
probably just gonna pull the pond and
hope that something nice happens on the
Kings side but Petrosyan is a gentleman
and he goes back with the night night
Stewie one other a nice move as
petrosyan here really finds a nice you
know the core of the position he sees
that Fischer put all of his pawns on
dark squares and Fischer's dark square
Bishop isn't all that great
well on the other hand this light square
bishop is very powerful so by playing
nice to you one Petrosyan prepares the
exchange of light square bishop he wants
the you know eliminate Fischer's light
square bishop and leave him with a bad
bishop and okay Fischer continuous
display on the queenside B 5 and we have
Bishop to g4 Bishop captures Queen
captures Petrosyan achieves his plan and
immediately Queen to c8 Fischer offers
now a queen trade patrols and declines
it trading Queens here it's not it's not
bad but you know black controls more
space there's really no reason to do it
Wood moves like g6 f5 this dark square
Bishop can even come alive so instead
Queen back to e2 nice to d7 we'll have
nice to see to and now comes rock to b8
we have roped a c1 now if something like
B captures on c4 happens then
Petrosyan was gonna capture with the
night which would give him a nice open C
file for the rook
of course Fischer isn't interested in
this rook F 2 c1
now comes the Queen to e8 Bishop to a3
and now Bishop to d6 by Fischer
Petrosyan is kinda trying to get b4 out
of Fischer and then after Bishop to b2
now it's
a five he wants to break open with a
move like a three or even closed the
position with a four and then try to
force Fisher - perhaps captain Poisson
but this would never happen so he would
pose the position and then tries
transfer the game over to the Kings side
okay brush up to a three Bishop to d6 by
Fisher and now comes Knight back to e1g
6 we have seek after some b5 a capture
some beef event now Bush back to be two
knights to b6 and now Knight to f3
rook to e8 and now comes a 392 a5 as now
by playing a three Petros and did weaken
the b3 squared
Queen to d1 adding further protection to
B 3 and the now Queen to f7 again
increasing pressure to 2 B 3 and also
preparing f5 we have a for a captures a
captures and now see for this c4 is a
very nice move by playing this Petrosian
did create a nice past a pawn but
Fischer place
c4 and now as he controls c4 with two
knights and the Queen it's a very nice
move that forces White's to recapture
because c3 is a threat Petrosyan cannot
allow D captors on c4 Knight a captors
and c4 captures captures and now Queen
to e2 I would a double attack against
the night there's no way of actually
saving this Bishop so you know you have
to play something we need to guards the
Bishop Fisher captures the bishop we
have Queen captures and now comes look F
to b8 attacking the Queen Queen to a2
offers a trade of Queens Bishop to b4
Queen captures King captures and now
rook to c7 check and Fischer place came
to e6 so now we have entered in the
endgame and we have to see what we're
dealing with here but Rosen has a nice a
a pest a pond while Fischer has a nice
past deep on but Fisher's D pawn is also
a protected passed pawn which is much
more important even though this is an
outside passed pawn a protected passed
pawn is is a better pass pawn so Fisher
is slightly better here and it's it's a
question if the Trojan will be able to
to protect his passport so okay we have
g4 here
Fisher actually invited Petrosyan to
capture on h7
but pitocin is not in a rush to do this
first he pushes G for not allowing
Fischer to push f5 so okay we have
Bishop to c3 refresher attacks the rook
on a one look to a2 and the now comes
rook the c8 offers a trade of rooks here
a Fischer actually invites patrols in to
capture on age seven and this probably
would have been a very nice move for
example if rook captures here then you
get route to C for attacking the pass
born here and then after a five or
something you have to capture because
there's no way to protect the a for pawn
anymore so after a5 captures captures
captures and now when the roof tries to
get back into the game you play Bishop
to b4 rope to a6 check came to f7 and
now you will simply keep checking the
black King you give a check then the
King moves and now you simply keep
checking the King and now you have this
g5 move g5 move trying to further
destroy black's pawn structure but then
black has to decide what to do and the
best move in the position is d3 but it
doesn't give black all that much for
example rook to a7 check King moves now
you can simply keep checking the king
and after King finally attacks the rook
then you put the room behind the passed
pawn and you can no longer push the
passed pawn as it's protected so after
captures you can simply capture the d3
point and it's it's a it's a nice
position for both white and black but as
this is most 33 and they haven't still
reached time control Petrosyan was most
likely down on time he decides not to go
for this complicated line he decides to
capture the rook we have rook captures
rook captures into now a five but rosin
starts pushing his passed pawn rook to
e8 we have a six now and now rook to a7
blockading the pawn so Fisher doesn't
follow up it wasn't to push it any
further and also keeps an eye on the h7
point for now King to f1
now that everything has been done
petrosyan decides to bring the King over
into the game we have g5 King to e2 and
now King to d6 Fischer does the same
King D three pink to c5 and now tonight
the g1
the night isn't very useful and f3
petrosyan wants to bring it into the
game via e2 to attack the bishop hmm
we have King Tubby 5 and Ranaut Knight
to e2 attacking Fisher's Bishop Bishop
moves to a5 and now you can see that the
a6 pawn will fall as there is no way to
defend it so perhaps that line you've
seen where Petrosyan grabs the h7 point
and in return gives up this pawn would
have been better because now Fischer
will simply be up upon so okay rook the
B to check Fischer captures and now rub
the b1 we have worked the c7 now this is
a very nice move by facial droop to c7
you can't move the King there's no way
nowhere for you to move the King the
rook is controlling the entire C file
the bishop is slicing all the way here
and the point is guarding d3 square so
you can never move the King but you can
also never move the knight if you move
the knight then you allow rook to c3 so
it's a very very passive position for 40
grand and there's not much you can do
here he tries Luke to be to simply
playing a move Bishop to e1 by Fischer
he forces the point to come to f3 we
have f3 and now King to a5 a Fischer
brings the King into the game we have
looked the c2 offering a trade of rooks
and here rook to be 7 by Fischer you
don't want to trade rooks even though
you are for example captures captures
even though you're up upon all of your
pawns are on light squares at one point
you will push h3 and then your king is
on a light square you will simply move
your knight back and forth wherever
possible and a dark square Bishop and
the king will not be able to force the
White King off of a light squared so of
course not trading ropes rook to b7 and
now comes Luke to a2 with check King b5
rook to be to be to check now of course
you don't want to move the King to all
of the rook trade you have to block with
the butcher Bishop before and now rook
back to a to Fischer again plays rook to
c7 and Brooke the c7 is is actually a
beautiful move it's really really a
tricky move for example if petrosal
would offer a trade once again here
let's say rook to c2 then then this
seemingly harmless move would actually
lose you the game on spot
it's it's actually a very nice idea so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the reason why rook to c2
loses the game now how do you punish
this with black so I will give it a
couple of seconds for you to you know
try to figure it out as usual for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are you are a
brilliant endgame player and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy the movies
rook to a7 rook to a7 a really a
wonderful idea
the threat of course is rook to a3 check
the king has nowhere to go and you can
to block with the night or the rook
because the point is guarding c3 so what
can you do here well if you try to
create a square for the King for example
player up to be 2 so the King would have
a fight square it doesn't work because
simply rook the c3 check a3 check King
moves and now d3 check picks up the
knight King has to move you lose the
knight and the game another thing you
could try perhaps move the knight if you
move the knight then you can move your
king to e2 but this also doesn't work
let's say Knights to c1 rook checks now
you have to move the King and ok now the
night end the King are guarding the d3
square so you cannot pull the pawn but
you can play rook III check King moves
and now comes rope the c3 you force a
trade of rooks and after captures
captures now you have an endgame that's
completely winning for black but of
course you have to know that this
endgame is winning to be able to go into
this variation for example kingi - now
you simply bring the King into the game
King moves you attack the knight of
course white cannot afford this trade
you have to move the knight then King
comes closer into the game and now it's
all over as c2 and c1 are coming so this
rope the c2 would have been a terrible
blunder so tigran tries rock back to a1
we have looked to see it and now rope to
a7 again a lot of activity for this
route but there's not all that much to
do there Bishop to a5 Fischer now closes
the file for this rook so the rook can
go back and now what do you do here you
can either capture the pawn but
capturing the pawn would have been very
dangerous for example if rook captures
on h7 then you get rook to b6
you prepare you make some room for this
rook so he can enter the game and the
the Bishop from b6 prevents this work
from coming back to a7 so let's say rook
to h6 you if there's nothing to do you
can at least grab another pawn but it
doesn't work rook e8 roof captures on f6
now it's Petrosyan who would actually be
up upon but Roque 3 check King moves now
comes Bishop check King moves now comes
d3 tonight has the move now comes D to
Knight has to move and now root K 1
check wins the game King moves Queen
comes into the game and now Queen B 1
will be checkmate so after Bishop to a5
rope to d7 was played by Tigran we have
Bishop to b6 again Fischer prepares his
grand entrance of the rook rook to d5
cherishable blocks and this was deacons
idea why he didn't capture the pawn why
he played a rook on the D file now the
bishop is on c5 and the Fischer will not
be able to play rook to c3 so now the
grant can actually move the knight so
nice to see one he tries to activate it
via night b3 first roblox this king to
a4 rook to d7 and now we have the Bishop
to b4 preparing if rookie 7 check then
Fischer can always if rope here then the
bishop can block it also Knight has to
move as it was attacked Knight back to
e2 guarding c3 so King to b3 and now you
can see how masterfully Fischer brought
his king all the way to the b3 that's
that's quite a quite quite a nice King
March rook to b7 and now there's really
not all that much I can do here
Luke 2:8 was played played by Fisher and
now there's nothing to do here Petrosyan
simply decides to grab a pawn but it's
far too late for such things it was
possible some 30 moves ago but now not
so much
rook to e1 by Fischer an excellent move
pressure here is preparing rook to d1
of course although you can see that if
the grand for example place something
like Ruby 7 then rook to d1 will be
checkmate again bishop slices all the
way here the King now creates a wall
against the White King and to the pawn
is guarding d3 square another thing for
example if you try something like nice
to g3 to create a fight square it
doesn't work rook to a 2 now you
threaten the rook - D - checkmate Knight
has the block
nice to f1 now we play rock - f - and
now you win the night there's nothing
you can do here because if you move the
night again you get a rug D - checkmate
a very nice position for black
Petrosyan tried one the only thing he
could now Knight capture son before he
decided to give up a night for two pawns
captures captures and here you do have
two points for the bishop but it's it's
simply not enough rook to d1 check King
moves now comes the bishop check on c5
King - E - Luke - h1 not allowing this
rook to move from the H file we have h4
by petrosyan and Fischer simply ignores
this he brings the King into the game
we have h5 Petra now creates a passed
pawn but you will never be able to do
anything with it
rook to h2 check King you want and now
King to d3 and here are move 66 is where
Tigran Petrosian resigned and game 6
also went to the Bobby Fischer so an
excellent game and it's really really
amazing after after winning the first
game and then losing the second then
after three draws Fischer manages to win
Game six and well what a battle it was
60-66 moves
why did he resign well the king will
simply come to e3 and start picking up
all of the points there's nothing you
can do here
whatever you do well it's a check King
it theory or even you block with Bishop
King moves let's say you go for the f3
pawn the King can go up since the rook
is cutting off the King from the second
rank and whatever you play here
there should be five guards the rook
let's say will be seven and now King
captures on f3 and now all of the points
that will fall so yeah after the skin to
b3 move Tigran resigned and now the
result is 5 - sorry 3 to 2 in Fischer's
favor so like I said I already made a
video on Game seven about a year ago so
the link to it will be the first thing
you will see in the description below
feel free to check it out as I will be
making a remake so if you really you
know can't wait to see what happens in
Game seven but yeah that's it I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the Fischer series so far I would like
to thank
Marko's uninvolved Jose Diaz Singh Gwen
Souza matheus ferric and Mercury for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I'll see you
soon
hopefully with another interesting video
think I'll and I'll see you soon